okay our next speaker is going to be um
Jakob Vish who is the um head of product
data at the Platinum uh P data sponsor
Babel which is the world's uh top
growthing language app and so usually
when tech companies want to test causal
assump assumptions they do AB testing
however yakob is um trying to convince
Us in his talk that you can do um causal
inference on data even if you haven't
conducted experiment and with that
please take it
away all
right thank you very much everyone um so
I'm going to talk to you about quasi
experimental uh methods and in causal
inference and their practical pitfalls
before I get going to that I wanted to
ask uh get a little bit more of a feel
for why you are here so who in the room
is actually in the business of informing
human decisions with uh using
data
that's actually quite a lot who here is
in the business of informing machine
decisions using
data all right and who is here because
they were intrigued by the title of the
talk but don't really know what this is
about all right a couple of those as
well so what you will get out of this
talks depends on what you how you answer
that question if you're in the business
of um informing human decisions what I
hope you get out of this is a little bit
of a broader view over the toolkits that
you have available in the python open
open data stack
um you uh I will also give you a little
bit of a process um a workflow that you
can go through to avoid common pitfalls
um and I also walk you through a case um
uh in the in the domain of language
learning the the domain that Babble is
operating in if you're in the business
of informing um machine decision making
then I'm hoping that you get out of this
a couple of tools of how you can
actually identify um a couple of or your
um common confounders that might be
actually unobservable instead of set of
observable um and if you answer the last
positive to the last question I'm hoping
to give you a little primer um to this
domain to spark your
interest all right so let's start with
some some basic concepts um we've heard
this before why people like experiments
in AB testing um well we like it because
it gives us the core assumptions that we
need to solve the fundamental problem of
causal inference by design for free
that's why we like it so any kind of
confounder that we have that could um
essentially
um confuse or confound the the uh the
causal effects between a treatment A and
B um towards an outcome a uh y um that
is taken care of by Design just because
of the magic of Randomness what a quasa
experiment is and what I'm how I'm going
to be using it in the course of the talk
is what we're looking for is instead of
actually using actively Randomness to
assign a treatment we're looking for a
statement or for some assumptions that
we can um make based on properties of
the data generating process that allows
us to make a statement like as if random
so we're looking at a sample that or a
treatment that is as if randomly
assigned that's the core um the core
point of using quasa experiments for for
uh causal inference but that poses a
problem and that problem is related to
this kind of overview that every data
scientist or analyst has probably seen
or used themselves when talking to their
stakeholders their decision makers for
why they should invest in certain
methods to inform decision- making it's
essentially showing the the the
trade-off between the quality of
evidence that you can um that you're
basing your decision on and the cost of
evidence um that you have to uh take on
in order to get that um get that
information at the top of the pyramid
it's usually kind of called The Meta
analysis of randomized control trials
followed by actual AB test randomized
control styes then there comes this box
of quasa experimental designs then
variable end uh studies observational
studies expert opinion and my personal
favorite Intuition or the highest paid
person in the room
opinion now when we are zooming into
that quasi experimental design
box things get a little bit more
messy it is not for especially for
newcomers into this in this domain it's
not entirely clear where
um what you're actually buying into when
you're using a lot of the methods that
are employed in quas experimental design
so we've heard I think a talk before
about difference and difference
approaches stagger difference and
difference um we've heard a lot about um
uh about Cal ml so using type of um um
various uh instrumental variable
approaches or propensity score matching
but what you're buying into is
considerably difficult for you as an
analyst or a data scientist to actually
tell your decision maker
um hey these are the results that we're
seeing but hey these are the type of
assumptions that you're buying
into and that is a core problem when you
buy into kind of the basic tenant of my
talk which is good decisions require
knowledge or
information but knowledge is bought with
assumptions and if you treat your
assumptions as a currency it is your job
as a data professional to actually
assign a value to that like what am I
actually buying
into
so what I want
to give you um along at this first um in
this first part of my of my talk is this
relatively
straightforward um process or workflow
that you can go through in order to
avoid some common pitfalls and make it
easy for you to visualize and make your
assumptions um explicit to the decision
maker that you're
informing first one first up is start
with a causal model
a lot of times these types of methods
are uh geared to see looking at them and
saying oh I know that I have this type
of problem or this type of decision that
I could inform with this but start with
the problem and your causal model first
that will make it so much more easier to
shape your selection of methods um to
make your assumptions explicit to
whoever decision you are actually
informing um and it's generally going to
structure your thoughts about this this
the problem that you're looking at
second estimate when you're looking at
actually then estim after you've have
your causal model you've identified what
you actually want to estimate and what
assumptions um you're making that make
this estimate actually a causal
relationship consider multiple methods
to test your observational assumptions
uh implications usually um we're using
one particular method and in the case
that I'm going to show you in the second
part of the talk I'm also focusing on
one specific method um but generally
there are multiple ways that lead to
Rome and I can uh I can encourage
everyone to look into um multiple
methods when you're testing your
observational implications from your
causal model and last up refute your
assumptions and this is probably one of
the biggest um things to take care of
these types of methods these types of
processes and problems really gear to
the sunk uh cost fallacy you run all of
through this workflow you see kind of
nice uh effect sizes they're all
statistically significant and then you
clap your hands say oh great I I've
identified and shown a causal effect and
walk away but the crucial part is to
actually actively refute your own
assumptions because those are the
currency that your decision maker is
actually buying into when taking a
decision the good news about this is
that generally the open source stack and
the python uh open source stack in in
particular can help you do that and this
is a highly subjective user perspective
I'm not actually involved in any of
these these projects um but what I can I
wanted to give you a little bit of a of
a rundown of um some notable mentions so
I think one of the the um one of the
very um positive development is this
open source project from uh from
Microsoft called duy um their econ ml
package falls under that family what
they have set out to do is really give
you a endtoend process and or endtoend
tool to do causal INF
um using various methods so they will
give you really guide you through um
your causal graphs you they they they're
steering you to to uh input a causal
graph they're identifying the estimat
they have implemented methods um to to
actually do the estimation and then uh
implemented methods to uh to test your
assumptions uh another two notable
Dimensions that I'm also going to use in
the second part of my talk or one um
tool that is actually coming more of the
AR Community which is dagy which gives
you an easy way uh of online tool to
actually build your causal models using
directed ayrical graphs and and not only
that it's also giving you some um
pointers to which type of uh which type
of assumptions you're actually making in
order to properly identify an estimate
another um notable mention that I was
very positively uh um impressed by was a
package or project coming out of the PMC
Community which is caal pie which uh
also implements a couple of methods that
are very very prominent in the social
science particularly economics domain um
not so much in the data science data
analytics uh industry domain and I think
this package is also doing a very good
job at guiding through making these
methods more
usable all right but enough about the
abstract um let's get down to an actual
case uh from the domain of language
learning that um I want to walk you
through um in order to Showcase this
process and also a couple uh one
particular method which is regression
discontinuity design the case that we're
looking into is uh along the following
question are language Learners actually
motivated to learn more intensely if we
show them a higher proficiency
assessment why do we care about this so
instead of walking you through why my
stakeholders the decision makers at
bubble care about this think about or
take a second to think about your
favorite teacher in
school right I hope everyone has some
person in mind now think about the most
effective teacher in
school all right for me personally when
I think about those these are actually
two different
people and The crucial part that we're
continuously thinking and have to take
decisions on at Babble is are we going
to to be the lenient teacher that is E
aing on the easy side in order to
motivate our Learners to stick with
language learning or are we going to be
the little bit more rigorous more strict
teacher that is actually showing them um
okay here is something that you have to
learn here's something that you have to
brush up and that is often times a
trade-off and uh a lot of times
dieticians and uh decision makers that
we work with have um a a bit of a
leniency to more of the easy s side
under the assumption that that actually
incentivizes and motivates Learners to
continue to
learn now let's look at the data
generating process that we're um that
we're uh exploiting here so what I'm
going to look or uh at is um a feature
at Babble which is called the babble
English test it's a um multi-stage D
dynamically evaluated language
proficiency test in multiple stages um
now all the ml folks look at this and
say ooh neural network it's not a neural
Network it's just a dynamically
evaluated test where every at every
stage we're asking multiple questions
and evaluating um the user's proficiency
at at each Noe which with one very very
important property um of this process
which is the last node and at the last
node there is a fixed threshold that
decides whether a learner whose
proficiency we have evaluated up to the
last note will keep the or whether we
will display them the CFR level that
they've just um been evaluated with or
whether they're going to getting bumped
up by one CFR
level and that is the property that
we're going to exploit um in this case
for um identifying a causal effect a
couple of descriptives so about the
sample that we're looking at here it's
about 30,000 31,000 test takers u in the
course of the last year um the average
time spent learning within s days of the
test which is going to be kind of the
operationalization of um of learning
motivation that we're going to use or in
a a observable implication of that is
about 1.2 hours um the average score on
that final note that we're going to
exploit is about 66% so the majority um
um of Learners are actually below that
um 80%
threshold all right so how does that
work how can we um how can we think
about that how can we exploit that
property um in order to to answer the
question
does um the display of a crfr level
higher or lower actually affect um
causally affect the um the motivation
and the learning intensity of our our
Learners so first step do your think
about your causal model uh and I can uh
recommend to you to use directed astical
graphs uh we've heard the primer by
Judea Pearl which I can hardly recommend
on the uh on the topic but here's my
simple recom recommendation for why to
use directed AC acyclical graphs um
instead of other uh Frameworks that you
can use because it's reusable you can
reuse the graph that you're you have to
model your your causal process and to
actually explain then to your decision
maker for what they're buying
into but back to the case so what we're
exploiting here or the general problem
that we have is we want to estimate the
effect between showing a different CFR
level um and learning intensity
with a let's say an assumption that
there's some kind of motivation mediator
in the
middle now we can run a regression and
just look at okay how does uh a CFR
level um display actually correlate with
learning intensity but that is not
really well causally identified because
we have that hidden thing in the middle
which is the actual proficiency the
actual knowledge of the learner which we
cannot directly
observe in fact that's actually the
point for why we're doing the test right
right we want to have a proxy measure
for what the proficiency of the learner
is but this is a confounder because
proficiency will uh will very likely um
both affect the learning intensity that
users are showing after taking the test
as well as their actual uh crfr
assessment so that's a confounder and
even more problematic it's an OB
unobservable
confounder what we can do um in order to
exploit that fact that there is this um
this this
um non-continuous jump at this node is
we can treat our assignment variable
which is the success rate in the last
node as essentially deciding whether the
user gets treatment or not right so if
the user is above that 80% threshold
they will get treated they go going to
get bumped up by a CFR level if they're
not treated um they're uh they're going
to remain in their um CF R level so this
is a Stylz graph this is not actually
showing the data that I uh I referred to
before now Now The crucial
identification assumption that we're
making is as we are going closer closer
and subsampling just around that
threshold we're going to end up with
users that are roughly similar that are
as if randomly distributed why because
our test takers cannot very precisely
steer whether going they're going to be
above or below that 80% threshold that's
the crucial identification assumptions
that that we're making here
all right so step two in the process
estimate when we're looking at this um
and uh I'm I'm skipping over uh a couple
of different uh things that I recommend
you do uh other than just R running one
single model and then saying great um
what we're doing here is we're
essentially fitting two local
regressions around a bandwidth around
that 80% threshold from both sides um
you can get a lot more fancy on
depending on how your distributions look
like depending on certain assumptions
that you make about the data generating
process you can look uh inter fitting
nonlinear models you can use splines
there's a lot of different things that
you can do in order to make a more
robust um uh estimation here um but what
we find for this particular case if we
take a 10% bandwidth around the 80%
threshold um and fit local uh
regressions um on both sides of that um
of that bandwidth we end up with a um
roughly a negative 39 minutes um or
learning minutes effect um in the 7 days
after the uh our um Learners took the
test so this is um model uh is estimated
using uh caal pie I can hardly recommend
looking into that it's a relatively
early stage project but um I find it
very very usable and easy to to um to
understand all right so at that
point you might find yourself or your
decision maker asking um okay Jacob what
like so what um
well that negative effect of showing the
higher CFR level to me at least is quite
surprising um so one takeaway for
decision makers may be well if you're
thinking if you continue to think about
these kind of decisions that you make to
develop your product airing on the side
of more easy content more digestible
content
that assumption that you may have that
that is actually motivating is not
necessarily true and that is a
relatively easy kind of uh or quick to
to implement method to show that with
some more rigor than um uh just using at
uh correlations and
patterns but there are are a couple of
bigger caveats that we have to think um
think about when telling that to our
decision maker because you still have
sample selection potentially into who's
actually taking the test right depending
on how you expose that to your users you
might actually only get the users to
take the test who are already at a high
proficiency you might have all kinds of
different um selection problems that
this um um that uh that are even at an
earlier stage than uh the selection
within um the test
takers um another big bigger point and
we we've heard a couple of very good
talks on this topic is heterog
heterogenous uh treatment effects um so
one thing that you uh need to take care
of of and um I'm not going to get into
in the interest of time here um is that
effect that we see that negative 39
minutes might actually be different
across different CFR across different
levels of language Learners right so one
hypothesis is that for the easier for
the lower level language Learners that
effect might actually be positive um so
they there the motivational effect of
actually showing them hey you are
actually progressing higher um that
might be there whereas for the more
mature more the the advanced language
Learners um that effect might actually
then turn
negative um why is that important well
because that directly informs a decision
um by the team that is uh is iter maybe
iterating on on this assessment
feature all right just in terms of um
quick things to do to refute um a couple
of assumptions that we uh we made in
this analysis is um the two big ones for
for regression discontinuity design are
usually self- selection across the cut
off so when your learners or when your
subjects can actually have very precise
control of self- selecting across that
80% threshold then one of your core uh
identification assumptions goes out of
the window because then the as if random
statement across those 80% that 80%
threshold is not true
anymore one way of how to do that is is
to look at densities um across your
assignment variable your running
variable um so if user if your subjects
are actually self- selecting you would
see some bunching around the cutoff
right you wouldn't see kind of a a
smooth distribution you would see some
bunching on the cut off um which we
don't see in this case um but we do see
something else which is that the running
variable actually seems to follow not
necessarily a completely continuous
trajectory which has to do with the
number of questions that we ask each
node so that is something to look into
whether that actually breaks um uh a
couple of assumptions of regression
discontinuity design the other thing
that you can do is to um do coar
covariate or inspect your covariate
balances if you're as if random
assumption is two around the cut off
then any kind of other attributes about
your subject should be roughly balanced
across the left and the right side of
the cuto off within that 10% bandwidth
right so if you see that there's a hum
longus imbalance that is not uh that is
uh statistically significant that's a
pointer that something is going on that
actually tanks your um your the
assumptions that you're making in this
case uh I've just plotted and put some
some of those in the in a table here we
don't see any um major imbalances um uh
across the left side and the right side
of the cut
off all right coming to key
takeaways my first recommendation when
you are focusing on causal inference in
general but more specifically on using
quasa experimental methods so looking
for that as if random element in your
data generating process is work
backwards don't fall into the Trap of
looking at this talk and now saying oh
and now I'm looking for regression
discontinuities that design applications
think about your causal problem first
and then go forward to identify the
proper methods that you can use in order
to answer it that's um one big takeaway
second do put a lot of time into
actually thinking and uh plotting your
causal model because that will help you
and uh give you a reusable asset to
actually make your assumption this
explicit and third please do your best
to refute your assumptions um because
it's very easy for these methods to um
do this the classical stargazing um and
then walk away you really do have to
make an effort to disprove your own
assumptions here uh and last and that's
more kind of a a call to to explore
those packages there's a really really
thriving um uh open source uh project
landscape in Python coming up I come
from an R world where this is a lot uh
more uh mature I would say and I'm
really uh happy to see that this is um a
a growing community and lastly um if
you're interested in the stuff that I
talked about or you're looking for an
opportunity um we are still hiring at
bubble especially in the data domain
currently we're looking for uh data
manager and um Warehouse Engineers but
we're always interested in um in uh also
initial applications and I'm going to
leave that QR code up for the round of
questions that I'm opening up
for